pour ce parti soit les techniques de
chemin et les voir voilà voilà j'étais
prêt ok c'est bon gaulliste orléans
réponse
c'est en tout cas un repas trop en tout
cas un repas tout le monde tout ça tu
meurs voilà c'est vachement bon ça on
voit la montre
et on va passer cette rencontre jour ça
peut être très beau qu'on va vis et par
derrière passé comme ça là bas ça va
être très très très beau ça mais bon les
mecs comme ça au froid laval à toi je
voulais mettre comme ça à droite ça
c'est super tu fais un beau
c'est beau de les voir comme ça à la
date contre jours qui arrivent attention
pas bon pour toi dans leur ferons pas le
refaire en temps pour faire tampon 2 et
alors que vous dites ok adresse bon ça
ouais dans le grand écran ça va péter ça
peut-être un peu plus peut-être enfin
j'ai pas porté les se voit pas beaucoup
passé pour ses vaches
attention tu prends bien les tous les
chemins qui sont alors on atteint là
voilà
on tourne autour du puits commenté le
groupe prenne c'est bon pour toi ou
quand on fait trop vertical dans tout
match j'ai hâte écoles de wikio alward
au cabri canon qui arrivent dessus tout
bloquer à tout match bonbons notre
hockey atome a tué harry caul peter
crouch i just called to the last of the
past atout face à face dans le titre
face à
tyson est
bon pour toi
oui c'est bien gentil tout ça mais ce
que la rencontre jour arriva dans ce lot
les acv très très beau ça si vous allez
j'en prends là c'est super 14 avec
pension contre jour qui va être très
très fort malheureusement
on ne sait pas c'est le soleil
tu es arrivé à une vingtaine à
contrebalancer le truc où tu peux très
j'en
tiens c'est bien ça
on est bien là on fait un deuxième fois
et tu te rends tu essaieras de plus
ferme sur le réseau qui passait nos
équipes assurent eux ne bougent pas
voilà oiseaux qui va arriver sur eux
voilà voilà voilà c'est très beau ça tu
peux pouces il conviendrait aux qui
passait le sud du réseau pour sortir du
champ toi bayard yann oiseaux et un gros
groupe qui va passer tu t'écartes un
tout petit peu et car toi un peu écartée
voila voila il va passer de vendre un
peu il va passer à leur droite quand tu
es trop serré
parfois un petit peu et ouais pension tu
vas l'avoir voit les oiseaux qui passent
se trouve au centre est trop centré
toujours pas d'attention c'est parti
mais quand il ya deux groupes d'oiseaux
il passe de chaque côté de ces [ __ ]
fruits
de poser chemin c'est vachement pause
moi je pouvais pas la voir sur mon écran
alors là tu es trop attention tanguay
voilà c'est prêt
autour ok vous en servir le centre guy
un peu bien
d'accord c'est larry tu aimes ce que ça
fait un sujet bien avant c'est beau
c'est faux cette rivière tisser vous
devient qui passe en revue toutes
magnifiques c'est vrai qu'il est très
très beau de voir n'est pas trop dessus
un genre géant pour l'avant tour assez
loin
attention contre jour qui va arriver
tous parents je dirais qu'elle va c'est
très fort dessus ils arrivent ils
arrivent ils arrivent
attention le soleil va pas c est
carrément
dessus
ouais ça c'est pas terrible
écart toi bien pour bien voir les trucs
sur les chemins vont enfin
puis d'avoir été punis pour leur faire
dans l'enfer de refaire le hockey alors
faire je vais remplir les chemins qui
sont à leur droite alors droite voilà
voilà vachement toi voilà
partout un peu plus quoi
les chemins ce que je me voir sont
vraiment en dessous un
hélicoptère va passer voilà c'est ça je
veux voir voilà hélicoptère passe
d'ailleurs un peu moins de contre jour
ça va être moins fort ça va être mieux
malheureusement on va te montre tout à
l'heure
il se lie passe dedans
passé gauche ans
c'est magnifique ça avec la rivière
devant c'est vachement bourg je trouve
nom
du bot sous la dent
et deux sur full tilt troisième pays
très beau aussi aux puces et les animaux
qui a vendu 100
web en forme et vie comme avant tout
former also fin aux quais de saint quay
le cargo dans le but de former
ne sont plus marquées en interne le
patois est ce qu'il ya un je regarde
devant compagnie si l'on peut ni connu
passe dedans tu
parles pas paresseux caire
par régis
avec les herbes devant c'est vachement
beau arguer zerbe jour
juste à côté de la rivière
pension contre jour va arriver
voilà
c'est votre jour laisse par son
président
et comment pour vous
un moyen
ok go
qui
n'ont pas du tout politique si tu vas
partir pour avancer il n'ya pas le bio
bio quai cale ça va exactement les la
rivière qu'elle est gold by peter hall
il a été super
ok super thé enquête
c'était vraiment pour la matière de
diana mobile à l'arrêt julien labat y
accoucher musique volaille that he was
baissait un peu face à l'apathie hacker
couche épaisse
de rivière
je propose sa
rétention alors ne pas se passer
de matières
pertes en tout nous la voilà en contre
jour c'est super beau ça voilà voilà
trente ans rentre dans la danse
des oiseaux il y avait
une sorte pas
par là qu'ils vont passer leur
tour d'autres jouent aussi
plus d'herbe qui va devoir qui vous
rappellent ses superbes l'ars qui
pourrait il a tu vas voila voila
un petit palmier ou sûr
parce que par le passé passe pas le
biais là c'est pas cela du tout va bien
il est à gauche il à 9h pas la seule à
fonctionner
c'est pas terrible
passe bien fait bien en vertical
le plus gourmand verticale verticale dr
blais enfin votre guimbarde deux buts de
plus de vue d'un second souvent ce
souffle bonjour bien venir un casse-tête
on voit père sur les options n'a pas sur
les palmiers ma place sur les routes
nationales
ont relaté passe dessus voilà il fait
bien peu de la matière bien dense bien
verticale
ça c'est beau ça voilà c'est pour bien
finir la casse est comme ça
si l'oiseau suédoise aux pourparlers
avec support à
aller
sur le franc arrivant
alors que couvrir la guerre c'est pas
terrible mais
tokyo veut enfin
on peut changer ma cassette